but what we see ultimately is that the
x-men led by Cyclops really kind of back
off and they allow all these 198 mutants
or as many of them that x-force can
round up to actually leave the premises
and this is really kind of a hot topic
here this is really kind of a big
decision and the reason why is because
we don't know what's going on we don't
know if all these mutants are going to
join the side of Captain America we
don't know if these mutants are going to
join the side of Tony Stark we don't
know if they have simply just been
liberated by x-force and they're going
to go about their daily lives as
Morlocks or as criminals or whatever the
case may be we really have no idea what
it is that they want to do